Aman Allah'ım Merhaba
ve
Nasılsınız iyi misiniz
size böyle bakıyor olacağım birazcık ama
görmeye çalışıyorum Bir de süper Çok
mutluyum bugün burada olduğum için
Hayatta en sevdiğim şeylerden biri
birincisi Yazmak bir şeyler böyle
karalamak yazmak İkincisi de İnsanların
karşısına geçip bir şeyler anlatmak
boyunu anlatmak biliyorsunuz zaten Eee
tahminen bazılarınız beni tanıyordur
YouTube'dan diye düşünüyorum ama
[Alkış]
Çok teşekkür ederim canım babuşlar
tanımıyorsanız Eğer de ben Çilem Akar
YouTube'da Yıllardır İngilizce öğrenmek
öğretmek konuşmak günlük hayatta
İngilizceyi kullanmak işte oyun
İngilizce oyunlar
üniversite yurtdışı
yaşam tarzı bunlar üzerine videolar
çekiyorum 2015'ten beri ve bugün burada
olmamız sebebi Aslında normal bir
İngilizce öğretmeni olarak normalde
İngilizce öğretmeniyim bir İngilizce
öğretmeni olarak Ee normal de normal bir
kariyer yolu izlerken Bu yoldan bir risk
alıp Ee tamamen farklı bir yola girmek
ve şu anda hiç hayal bile edemeyeceğim
daha önce hayal edemeyeceğim bir noktaya
gelmek bu noktaya nasıl geldiğimi
anlatacağım Bir nebze Aslında ve bunu
anlatırken de kendi hikayemden
öğrendiğim şeyleri çıkardığım mesajları
size vermeye çalışacağım Bunun dışında
dil öğrenmekle alakalı zaten
yolculuğumda Bununla alakalı da çok şey
öğrendim öğretmekle alakalı Bununla
ilgili birkaç bir şey söyleyeceğim
üniversiteyle alakalı birkaç bir şey
söyleyeceğim bu şekilde
şu anda Eee YouTube'da yani 2015'te
açmıştım ve ilk başta Hobi olarak
Ee başladığım bir şeydi bu ve şu anda
full time Ee YouTube'dan II video
çekerek işte video paylaşımları yaparak
devam ediyorum Hayatımda ve 550.000
aşkın abonemiz var 45 milyondan fazla da
izlenmemiz var yani YouTube'da Eğer
İngilizce ile alakalı bir şey
araştırırsanız Muhtemelen videolardan
bir tanesi karşımıza çıkar şimdi bu
noktaya nasıl geldim dediğim gibi
bununla başlayacağım Öncelikle İngilizce
ile tanışma hikayemden başlamak
istiyorum ben Ee çok çok çok küçükken
tanıştım İngilizceyle ve benim şansım
şeydi babamın bilgisayarcı olmasıydı
arkadaşlar Böyle ilkokuldayken daha ne
bahsettiğim seneler 2004 2005 falan
bizim evde bilgisayar vardı Normal
şartlarda o için bu çok olan bir şey
değil yani her evde bilgisayar yok o
zamanlar ama benim dediğim gibi babamın
şansına bilgisayar vardı Her neyse ben
sabahtan akşama kadar bilgisayarda vakit
geçirmeye bayılıyordum Yani hiçbir
şekilde kalkmıyordum başına okula
gidiyorum kafamda şey var Eve gideyim de
bir an önce bilgisayara gireyim falan
Neyse
bilgisayarda o zamanlar internet
te sürekli İngilizce içeriklere maruz
kalıyordum yani bir şeyleri
araştıracaksam oyun oynayacaksam Ondan
sonra internette herhangi bir şey
yapacaksam mutlaka İngilizceyi
kullanarak yapmak zorundaydım Türkçe
içerik yoktu
Çünkü o yüzden yavaş yavaş İngilizceye
çok Aşina olmaya başladım çok Maruz
kaldım Çünkü ve farkındaysanız
da İngilizce Benim amacım değil yani Ben
bilgisayara İngilizce öğrenmek için
girmiyorum bambaşka şeyler yapmak için
giriyorum ve İngilizce benim için
sen mecbur
en bana duymam okumam gerekiyor ki işte
O bilgisayarda istediğim yerlere
girebileyim oyun oynayabileyim işte bir
şey böyle okuyabileyim falan Her neyse
böyle tanıştım Neyse
ister istemez aşinalığım oluşmaya
başladı ve Daha sonrasında Okulda da
İngilizce dersi görmeye başladık Ve ben
bilgisayardan ama Aşina aldım Ama bu
arada aşıladım sadece bilgisayardan
değil şey benim babam tam bir Britney
Spears hayranı Gerçekten müthiş bir adam
hey sahibi bir adam yani çok fazla bir
espri şarkıları vardı bilgisayarda işte
onları dinliyordum Her neyse Ondan sonra
okula gidince tabii ki En sevdiğim ders
İngilizce oldu çünkü çok aşinallığım
olduğu için artık böyle alışmışım ve
doğal olarak okulda İngilizce dersinde
çok eğleniyorum çok mutluyum vesaire
ve gerçekten de başarılıyım Çünkü çok
aşinayım daha sonra
Bugün artık böyle şey haline geldi Hani
böyle En sevdiğim ders ondan sonra
sürekli kullanıp yapmak istediğim bir
şey çünkü şunu keşfettim İngilizce ile
alakalı bir noktada şey oldu İnternette
kullanıyorum ya
Aaa kullanarak dünyanın bam
başkasız bir insanla iletişim
kurabilirim Vay be Hani o da olur orada
doğmuş bambaşka bir hayatı var ve ben
onunla İngilizce konuşarak anlaş
biliyorum Oha müthiş bir şeymiş
İngilizce öğrenmek diye böyle bir
aydınlanma Yaşadım ve bu aydınlanma
yaşadığında 5 6 sınıfta falandım hemen
böyle bir sürü yabancı arkadaş edinmiş
Tim orada İngilizceyi çok çok daha fazla
sevdim Zaten Neyse sonra ortaokula
geçtim İşte hala devam ediyorum Aynı
şekilde
o noktada bazı aile bir problemlerden
liseye girme sınavımız var bizim ama
oksı yaşım belli oldu çaktırmıyoruz o
zamanlar deniyordu ve Eee o sınava çok
hazırlanamamıştım ve
sayesinde bir düz liseye geçtim şimdi bu
düz lisede Normal şartlarda işte Anadolu
liselerinde ya da işte Özel okullarda
İngilizceye çok önem veriliyor düz
lisede çok fazla
üstünde durulan bir şey değildi yani
hani matematik fen okul Ondan sonra işte
sayısalcı ol Daha bu tarz şeyler vardı
Neyse ondan
oradan bayağı bir bakış açımı
şekillendiren ve bir noktada buraya
gelmemi sağlayan bir şey oldu o da
İngilizce tiyatro İngilizce tiyatronun
buradaki önemi şu dediğim gibi düz lise
değil ve oradaki İngilizce tiyatro
grubunu bir öğretmenimiz gönüllü bir
şekilde kurmuş yani hani böyle bir şey
yapmak zorunda değil karşılığında bir
şey almıyor gönüllü bir şekilde
İngilizce tiyatro grubu kurmuş ve biz
isteyen öğrenciler gidiyoruz o tiyatro
grubunda işte İngilizce senaryo
ezberliyoruz bayağı Shakespeare'in
oyununu oynamıştık yani Ve o noktada
Benim İngilizcem baya ilerledi senaryo
ezberleyince bir sürü cümle gördüm
kalıplarını Çünkü ezberleyip Ondan sonra
onun üzerinden yeni cümleler kurmak
böyle
Bu yöntem çok işime yaramıştı o zamanlar
Yani
normalde dediğim gibi böyle bir şeye
zorunlu değil tamamen gönüllü yapıyor ve
bize çok büyük bir katkısı olmuştu Bu
olayın ve dedim ki
ben de böyle biri olmak istiyorum yani
İnsanların hayatına dokunmak istiyorum
ve bunu gerçekten hani onların gideceği
yerde bir katkım olsun hayatta
gelecekleri yerde bir katkım olsun diye
yapmak istiyorum ve bu beni çok tatmin
edecek diye düşündüm o öğretmenimden
ilham olarak ve dedim ki ben de bu tarz
bir şey yapacağım kesinlikle hangi
mesleği yaparsam yapayım İnsanların
hayatına dokunacağım dedim Her neyse
Ondan sonra lise 2'de okul değiştirdim
dil bölümüne geçmek için kafayı bozmuşum
İngilizce Okuyacağım da İngilizce
okuyacağım diye Her neyse Ondan sonra
Okulu değiştirdim dil bölümüne geçtim
lise son sınıfta Japonca okumaya karar
verdim o zaman anneme falan çok
seviyordum işte Japonca müzik
dinliyordum
Çığlık yapacağım dedim ki ben Japonca
okuyacağım başka bir şey okumak
istemiyorum diye ve ben bu hedefimi
koyana kadar arkadaşlar lisede hep şeydi
nasılım biliyor musunuz ya işte
üniversite geçeriz ya gireriz ya hani
hangi bölüm olursa yani çalışırız ya
Önemli değil falan şeklinde düşünüyordum
ama
tahmin edersiniz ki bu düşünce ve çok
bir yere taşımayacaktı Çünkü diyorum ki
ya tam bir tarih üniversiteye gireriz
işte yalandan Test çözüyorum falan ne
zaman ki dedim ki Eee ben Ankara değil
sadece coğrafyada Japonca okuyacağım
dediğim anda arkadaşlar bambaşka bir
Çilem doğdu Çünkü artık somut ve beni
inanılmaz heyecanlandıran bir hedefim
vardı Ve bu hedefi gerçekleştirmemenin
korkusu beni öyle bir Ee yani
gerçekleştirmemenin korkusu ve
gerçekleştirme ihtimalinin Hani keyfi
beni öyle bir çalışmaya gitti ki sabah
akşam çalışmaya başladım yani hani dedim
ya Ortaokulda lise Geçen gün hiç öyle
bir şey işte test çözeyim Bilmem öyle
şeylerle alakam yoktur şimdi Hani mesela
dershanede 10 tane yanlışım oluyor
atıyorum coğrafyada eve geliyorum Sabaha
kadar ağlıyorum Aman Allah'ım işte ee
bir sürü yanlışım oldu ben işte nasıl
kazanacağım orayı falan filan diye
korkunç bir şekilde motivasyon patlaması
yaşıyorum ve çalıştım Çalıştım çalıştım
tahmin edeceğiniz üzere En sonunda Eee o
bölüme girecek puanın da üstünde ve puan
aldım
Çünkü iyi gözümün önüne geçiyordum
arkadaşlar bunu sizin için de söylüyorum
işte tercihlerin açıklandığı gün işte
Ankara dil tercih coğrafya kazandınız
görüntüsünü kafamda hayal etmek bana
inanılmaz keyif veriyordu inanılmaz
heyecanlandır
ıyor ve bu belli gerçekten Günden güne
Gündem ne sürükledi üniversite sınavına
kadar Neyse ben puan aldım tek bir
tercih Ankara dil tarihte
ben oraya gideceğim Benim hedefim orası
dedim Neyse sonra annem devreye girdi ve
bayağı şey yaptı böyle işte ee
böyle bir Japoncada nasıl iş bulacaksın
Ondan sonra işte öğretmenlik oku Daha
garanti olur işte daha kolay iş bulursun
japoncadan para kazanamazsın falan diye
böyle 2 hafta boyunca böyle beynimi yedi
arkadaşlar ve ben en sonunda pes edip
Türkiye'deki bütün İngilizce
öğretmenliği bölümlerini yazmış bulundum
yetmiyorum Bu arada Çünkü dediğim gibi
Türkiye'deki bütün İngilizce
öğretmenleri neredeyse 29 tercih yaptım
ya Hangisi gelecek belli değil falan
böyle o yüzden Eee
yazdım geçtim dedim annemin hissediyorsa
artık hangisi gelirse umurumda değil tek
benim istediğim şey japoncaydı
terzilerin açıklandığı gün geldi beni
arkadaşım aradı En yakın arkadaşım
Onunla beraber planlamıştım böyle o
Korece Bence Japonca diye o koreceye
gitti Ben biraz satış olmuş oldum
maalesef aradı beni şey dedi falan filan
dedi Şey hani tercihimi açıp o Baktı ben
dedim ki ben bakamayacağım Hani sen bak
arada şey dedi Çilem şeyi kazandım
Eskişehir'i dedim ki Eskişehir'in neresi
ya götürmüyor mu yani
hiç asla tavsiye etmediğim bir
üniversite tercih hikayesi buradan şey
yapmayın geleceğim nokta bu başka her
neyse sonra Eskişehir'e gittim ilk dönem
inanılmaz mutsuzum Ben yatay geçiş
yapacağım Bu arada şehir dışında
okuyanların ilk şeyidir bu eee
karşılaşırsınız eğer öyle bir şey olursa
ben yatay geçiş yapacağım kendi Şehrime
dönüyorum Ama kimse yapamaz
Neyse sonra Eskişehir'de başladım
arkadaşlar Eskişehir'in özel olmasının
sebebi birincisi İngilizce öğretmenliği
bölümü Anadolu Üniversitesi İngilizce
Öğretmenliği bölümü çok güzel bir bölüm
gerçekten çok iyi bir eğitim aldığımızı
düşünüyorum ikincisi Erasmus programıyla
orada tanıştım zaten YouTube'da
videolarım da var Erasmus programı ile
alakalı üniversitede yurt dışına
gidebiliyorsunuz bu burslu bir şekilde
değişimi öğrencisi olarak Her neyse ben
İspanyolca dersleri alıyordum
üniversitede dedim ki erasmus'la
İspanya'ya gideyim En azından aldığım
dersleri pekiştiririm sonra arkadaşlar
Erasmus programına başvurdum sınavlarına
girdim ve gerçekten kazandım 6 ay
volvo'da Endülüs bölgesinde 3 ayda
barcelona'daydım Barcelona'da staj
yapıyorum Tamam mı sene 2015 evdeyim
sıkılıyorum dışarı çok çıkmıyorum Euro
çünkü hani staja gidip geliyorum
dışarıya böyle 40 yılda bir çıkıyorum
Dedim ki ben bu evdeki vaktimi bir
şeyini değerlendireyim Sıkıldım yani
oyun oyna nereye kadar bunu aldım
YouTube'u çok izliyordum zaten senelerde
dedim ki ee acaba işte Bilgisayar falan
varken edit programı indirsem YouTube
videosunu çeksem diye önce bir
arkadaşlarımla paylaştım dediler ki ya
işte ya biz izleriz bilmem ne dedim
tamam da zaten barselona'dayım çıkayım
dışarı barselona'yı çekeyim ondan sonra
atayım dedim gerçekten de öyle yaptım
çıktım telefonumla Samsung telefonumla
şey çekiyorum Barcelona'yı çekiyorum
falan işte burası şurası Burası böyle o
video Bu arada hala kanalda
arkadaşlarım izler annemler izler falan
böyle açtım kanalı
birkaç gün durdu işte
tahmin edersiniz ki öyle izlenmedi Yani
insanlar bana Barcelona'ya nasıl
geldiğimi dili nasıl öğrendiğimi sormaya
başladılar ve ben diyorum ki bununla
alakalı bir video mu yapsam diye Çünkü
böyle bir talep geldi dedim
Tamam video yapacağım ve ilk İngilizce
videomu çektim
eğlenceli bir şekilde İngilizce nasıl
öğrenirim diye O da duruyor hala
gerçekten hiperaktifim o videoda
inanılmaz
böyle çok şey bir
Hayal bir video
o videoyu çektim ve o video arkadaşlar
inanılmaz izlendi ve YouTube'da böyle
içeriklere ihtiyaç olduğunu o noktadan
anladım Her neyse ondan sonra
Bu videoyu da çektikten sonra ben zaten
Barcelona'dan Eskişehir'e geri döndüm
öğrenci hayatıydı şuydu buydu derken ben
YouTube kanalına
Aydın alakam yok Bu arada hala telefonla
çekmeye devam ediyorum Eskişehir'de
çekiyorum falan
şey vakti geldi üniversiteden mezun olma
ve mesleğim ne olacak
Biz öğretmenliğinde olay şu
yani insanların yüzde sekseni KPSS'ye
gireyim bir yere yerleşeyim Eee işte
devlette çalışayım şeklinde düşündüler
ve gayet mantıklı gayet güzel gayet
tatmin edici meslek Ben Ee şeyi çok
istiyordum arkadaşlar yıllarca İngilizce
öğrenmeye çalışmış ama bir türlü
öğrenememiş sorunu kendisinde zanneden
ama aslında kendisine bir sorun olmayan
insanlara aşılamak Çünkü okulda
İngilizce öğretime sistemini Biliyorum
ben de Türkiye de öğrendim İngilizceyi
yani sadece
Özel İl istiyorum o yüzden dedim ki ben
üniversitede çalışacağım
şimdi alesiye desteğe girmek gerekiyordu
falan ben bu hedefi belirledikten sonra
tekrar bakın bir hedef belirledim
belirledikten sonra hem ortalama uçtu
hem de alesiye dese yapabildim Hatta
ALES'ten önceki gün şey Özge burada dans
şey yarışmasına gitmiştik oradan sonra
tekrar ALES'e gitmiştik falan Ona rağmen
güzel bir puan alabilmiştim Çünkü
dediğim gibi çok net bir hedefim var
istediğim bir hedefim var Ondan sonra
onu yaptık
girdim sonra İstanbul'a döndüm bir tane
üniversitede işe başladım ve
üniversitede şöyle bir şeyle karşılaştım
Arkadaşlar öncelikle gerçekten bir
sessize söylediğim kitle ile karşılaştım
yani işte İngilizceden nefret edenler
hayatı boyunca görmüş hiçbir şekilde
ilgisi olmamış olanlar bir şekilde
öğrenememiş sorunu kendisinde zanneden
işte hiçbir şekilde yani hayatı boyunca
benim bu İngilizceyi halletmem lazım
diye böyle bir sıkışmış kendi içerisinde
çok fazla insan gördüm üniversite
öğrencisi gördüm hazırlıkta çalışıyordum
ve dedim ki ben kesinlikle Umut
aşılayacağım YouTube kanalımı kapattım
tamamen dedim öğretmenliğe odaklanıyorum
ve sınıfta şey yapmaya çalışıyorum
arkadaşlar Bir de hani müfredat
veriyorlar kitap veriyor
bunu Türkiye ya Ama şöyle bir uygulama
var bununla yapalım işte teknolojiyi
kullanalım bakın işte günlük hayatta
böyle kullanabilirler filmleri dizilerin
müzikleri kullanalım Ne bileyim işte
yabancı arkadaş edinmeleri için hani
böyle şey yapalım falan Okul yönetim
beni böyle dinliyor
işini yap anne ne yapıyor böyle niye
böyle şeyler geliyor sana kitabı takip
et işte diye bakıyorlar ve Ben koca bir
hayal kırık içerisine düştüm ve dedim ki
hayır
dil gerçekten matematik gibi oturup
kitaptan öğrenilen bir şey değil ben
kendi yöntemimde öğretmek istiyorum ve
derslerde böyle 20 dakikalık işte
bölümler ayırıp
öğretmeye çalışıyorum Kendi
yöntemleriyle işte eğlenceli bir şekilde
bir şeyler yapmaya çalışıyorum ama çok
işe yaramıyor bazı öğrenciler de işe
yarıyor Çünkü herkesin kafasında şu var
hazırlığı geçmem lazım yani böyle Gerçek
bir bağlı oldukları motivasyon yok o
yüzden Eee daha büyük bir şey yapmam
lazım dedim ve YouTube kanalımı Geri
açtım orada artık hani şey dedim
şeyden çekiniyordum öğrencilerle
aramızda çok az bir yaş farkı var ve
Hani saygı duyma olayını bir YouTube
kanalındaki halimi biliyorsunuz benim
böyle Lay Lay Lom Hani öğretmenlerin
öyle görmesinler diye Sonra şey ne
düşündüm zaten notlarını Ben veriyorum
yüzüme bir şey söyleyemezdim Muhtemelen
diye YouTube kanalını Geri açtım ve o
günden beri İngilizce içerikli videolar
üretiyorum ve videolarımla alakalı en
çok aldığım şey eee gerçekten hani
dediğim gibi İngilizceyi sadece Kitap
üzerinde kelimelerden ibaret gramerden
ibaret bir şey değil de
kullanabileceğimiz bir araç olarak bir
insanla konuşmak için kullanabileceğimiz
bir araç olarak görebilmek Ondan sonra
gerçekten dünyaya açılan bir kapı
olduğunu görebilmek ve aslında kadar zor
olmadığını görebilmek Aslında
videolarımda benim ortak hepsinin alt
metini Bu gerçekten eğlenceli hayatınızı
Entegre ederseniz Mutlaka yap
abilecek size inanılmaz fırsatlar
açabilecek bir şey yani ön yargılarınızı
kırmaya çalışıyorum ve o günden beri de
gerçekten
550.000 kişi toplandık ve
hayatında en mutlu olduğum şey ne diye
sorarsanız gelen şu gibi mesajlar bugüne
kadar İngilizceyi yapamıyordum işte
sevmiyordum ön yargım vardı artık
yapabiliyorum hep bende bir sıkıntı var
zannediyordum ama şöyle öğrenmem
gerekiyormuş şunu şunu yapmam
gerekiyormuş Bu benim için en en en en
en en büyük mutluluk oldu şimdi ben
sonra zaten arkadaşlar toparlıyorum
sonra zaten işte üniversiteyi bıraktım
full time YouTube yapmaya başladım
oradan beni hikayemizi biliyorsunuz
zaten Eee şu anda
Koskocaman bir şey ee aileyiz diyesim
geldi
arkadaş grubuyuz demek istiyorum ben
böyle birbirimizle çok faydalı bilgiler
paylaştığımız eğlendiğimiz bir arkadaş
grubuyuz ve son olarak benim hikayemden
çıkardığım ders Arkadaşlar öncelikle
çoğumuz gerçekten birçok şeyin
başındasınız mutlaka ama mutlaka bir
hedefiniz olsun yani farkındaysanız ben
kendi hikayemde şöyle bir şey yaptım
Hani hep kısa süreli hedeflerim vardı
bundan bir ay sonra şunu yapmış olacağım
3 ay sonra bunu yapmış oluyorum 5 sene
Sonrasında da okey Hedef koyabilirsiniz
ama daha komutu olması için kısa süre
hedefler ve sizi heyecanlandıran
hedefler Eğer sevdiğiniz bir şey
yaparsanız mutlaka para kazanacak bir
yolunu bulursunuz Ben Bence Japoncada
okutaydım bir şekilde bu noktaya
gelecektim diye düşünüyorum o yüzden
size heyecanlandıran sevdiğiniz
sizin yeteneklerinizi ortaya
koyabileceğiniz bir şeyler yapın Çünkü
hepimizin arka planları işte ilgi
alanları yetenekleri kabiliyetleri
farklı herkes aynı şeyi yapamaz belli
kalıpların içine oturamayabiliriz ve
bunda hiçbir problem yok Tek yapmamız
gereken şey bize her sabah heyecanla
uyandırabilecek bir hedefimiz olması ve
şunu da unutmayın şimdi Benim anlattığım
hikaye tereyağından kıl çeker gibi
yapmışım gibi olabilir ama şu beni çok
motive ediyor size de söylemek istiyorum
o yüzden
başarı ya da işte gitmek istediğiniz
yere hiçbir zaman alttan başlayıp böyle
Eee yani böyle doğrusal bir şekilde
gitmezsiniz her zaman inişler çıkışlar
olur
hiçbir zaman o yüzden motivasyonunuzu
kaybetmeyin yani böyle bir iki ay şu
şekilde gidip yükselip sonra tak diye
düşüp sonra tekrar azıcık yükselip düşüp
tekrar yükselebilirsiniz başarı böyle
bir şey arkasında karmaşık bir hikaye
olabilir o yüzden sakın Pes etmeyin ve
heyecanınızı Dinç tutun
heyecanlıysanız doğru yoldasınız Siz
konuşmanız Dilediğiniz için teşekkürler
[Alkış]